ja wir kommen bei der sendung von 4cast
über das thema wie hält man referaten er
um auch mit einer anekdote zu beginnen
ich hatte einen kommilitonen der ein
referat gehalten hat was nur aus mein
geld wohl angenehmste stand also der hat
sich verschiedene items zusammengesucht
die aberwitzig waren und und die dann
immer ein thema angesprochen haben
letztendlich hat sich herausgestellt
dass er eigentlich am morgen das referat
hat in museen und das gemacht habe aber
alle haben gelacht und irgendwie war es
witzig und dann war halt die frage was
kriegt ja für die präsentation war gut
er hatte ja schon vorher tragen einfach
das war strukturiert da hat eine
powerpoint-präsentation es gab es ein
paar damen mit denen hier erfüllt hatte
jetzt gehen wir mal davon aus dass das
wir hier auf einen interesse
interessanten stoßen werde er wirklich
interessiert am thema ist und eine
präsentation vorbereiten will
was das ist dennoch über wasser ist
dennoch notwendig für so eine
präsentation außerdem dieser portfolien
die man klassischerweise x einfügt ja
man braucht nicht nur powerpoint zu
erwähnten man kann auch ein gutes
referat halten ohne powerpoint zu
verwenden
das ist klar wichtig ist jedenfalls was
du auch schon gesagt hast dass man
referat möglichst frei hält also jeder
kennt die situation dass da jemand vorne
steht und einfach nur von seinem blatt
abliest
da schläft wieder ein das ist nicht
interessant und deswegen war dein
beispiel auch ziemlich gut gewählt man
hat fast mehr vom referat wenn es ein
bisschen provoziert und irritiert als
wenn es nur so ganz an der sache
thematisch orientiert ist deswegen wären
mein tipp ein referat durchaus ein
bisschen lockerer zu beginn vielleicht
mit einer anekdote oder mit dem beispiel
das aus dem leben gegriffen ist um die
aufmerksamkeit des publikums auf sich
ziehen
um es zu packen so dass und dann kommt
das alles möglichst frei zu halten hat
sich jetzt er sich so einfach denn die
nachrichten zu schauen irgendwie aus dem
leben gegriffen das thema aus und dann
darüber zu reden
ja es war ihm rassismus faschismus
relevant sei das ist gar nicht so leicht
wie erreicht man so was wie was ist denn
der kernpunkt wie was ist denn der
hauptgrund dafür dass man ein gutes
referat macht dass man einen ganz klaren
fokus hat ein referat interesse ist
genau das interesse bündelt im referat
hat nur bestimmte zeit zur verfügung man
hat vielleicht fünf bis zehn minuten zur
verfügung die nach seminar kann es
unterschiedlich sein aber ein referat
sollte ihr kurz sein und dann muss man
sich eben konzentrieren das heißt man
muss mehr noch als bei hausarbeit es
wichtige kommen weniger wichtigen
unterscheiden
das heißt man muss montiert werden wie
schon bei hausarbeiten auch eine
leitfrage ganz portiert sich aussuchen
und die möglichst frei und verständlich
kommunizieren
das ist wichtig dann komme ich gleich zu
der frage heraus und gibt es probleme
dass die sehr überfüllt und auch in der
philosophie ist es besonders schwierig
weil wir haben eine komplexe themen zu
zusammenhänge die irgendwie strukturiert
ganz kurzen klar das papier gebracht
werden
das problem dabei ist dass viele noch
gewohnt sind stichpunkte zu machen
warst du da irgendwelche selbst ja das
sieht man häufig in theesen blättern da
sieht wie du sagst zu überfüllt sind und
dass da nur stichpunkte sind oder so
viele also stichpunkt und dann so ein
pfeil und dann kommt ein neuer satz
das problem ist aus diesem pfeil geht
gar nicht genau hervor was das jetzt
bedeutet er wird daraus folgt dass oder
das ist noch interessant oder das ist
ein gegensatz das ist nicht klar also
solche kleineren zeichen sind ihr nicht
so gut geeignet von teese bleibt beim
referat einfach weil sie nicht
selbsterklärend sind deswegen würde ich
empfehlen beim referat sich zu
konzentrieren beim thesen blatt aus
formulierte sätze zu schreiben gerne
kommentiert oder thesen artig und zu
kombinieren also die wichtigsten thesen
ihn setzen ihm auf diesem textblatt den
teilnehmern auszuhändigen und um diese
thesen herum dann das
eigene referat zu kopieren okay wir
haben wir noch irgendwelche punkte
ja ich denke auch da kann es nicht
schaden sich mit dem dozenten in
verbindung zu setzen da vormals
vielleicht mal anzusprechen und was auch
ganz wichtig ist dieses referat vorher
ein paar mal zu üben
bis fr gespräche zu trainieren also zum
beispiel der kommilitoninnen und
kommilitonen einfach mal zu halten
vorträge oder zur not vor dem spiegel
oder sich selbst mal aufzunehmen mit der
kamera und dann zu schauen was kann ich
noch verbessern
an der art und weise wie ich spreche an
zusammenhängenden stil oder aber auch
wie meine gestik ist ob mal augenkontakt
da es solche dinge kann man sehr gut zu
hause vor dem spiegel oder mit freunden
trainieren perfekt ja vielen dank
es war gute tipps vielleicht helfen sie
mir auch noch weiter und wir sehen uns
bei der nächsten folge von 4cast zorns